I've got two most with people bite and
avoid continuing my little
self-indulgent trip down memory lane
through the Whedon verse and we get to
angel and as I do with Buffy I want to
start with my top 10 favorite episodes
of Angel this one was a lot harder to do
than Buffy and not for the reason some
people might be snarky Oh were there
even a good episode I actually like
angel a lot and taking complete as a
show I might even like it better than
Buffy which is a statement I'm gonna
have to explain at some point because
that is a very specific way in which I
feel it's better but that's not what
this video is about I'm sure I'll get to
that eventually so the reason this was
hard is because unlike Buffy looking
through the episode list the titles
there were really indicative and like I
see the title to go oh yeah I remember
that when I remember without titles for
angel episodes tended to be one word
that didn't really indicate what the
episode was so I had to look at a lot of
synopses to remember what happened in
which of these episodes but beyond that
a lot of my favorite moments were
payoffs to story arcs that happened over
a number of episodes not to the point
that you would call them like two
parters but like things built up to a
moment that I loved but then when I
actually figure out where that happened
I realized the episode that moment
happened in was okay it's just that
moment I loved so trying to come up with
a top ten episodes where I feel the
product as a whole is a truly great
thing as opposed to just like a really
killer moment that was a wonderful
payoff to stuff that been building that
was hard this thing this thing took me
way more work than I thought it was
going to but I got it put together so
here we go with top 10 episodes of Angel
starting with number 10 are you now or
have you ever been this in a lot of ways
was where the
really started to come into his own this
is the episode from season 2 where we
get the background on the hotel that
becomes the new digs for Angel and his
crew after the destruction of the very
generic offices that they had in the
first season the first season has a lot
of problems and not a ton of highlights
but this really became the marker of
where we are improving this we're not
just gonna do what we got away with
doing last time we're gonna make this
better and the way that it digs into
angels own past and the things that he
was willing to do even at the points
where he had a soul by this point he
still was not really a good guy and even
when he tried to be he found himself in
a situation where it didn't work out
well for him you know there's a reason
that it took falling for Buffy to truly
turn him into a hero and we see this and
we see this flashback in this history
and we get a sense of why he didn't have
it in him to be that before because we
see a time that it really bit him in the
butt money tried to connect with
somebody and there's a nice melancholy
to it and it's seeds something that is
such a recurring thing throughout the
entire show which is paying for your
sins I mean they're this show is nothing
if not a long string of characters
paying for their sins paying for their
mistakes whether it is even in excess of
the original sin committed but you made
a mistake you will pay for it eventually
no getting around that and this episode
feels like the real first firm start of
that becoming such a recurring major
element of this show and it's a pretty
good dang story besides number 9
Apocalypse Now ish I have a feeling this
probably wouldn't be on a lot of other
people's top tens but I really do enjoy
this episode for me it was terrifically
bill 2 which was something I mentioned
in my lead-up to this but as a
culmination in and of itself I liked it
a lot I loved the build-up to the beast
I loved the beast
I think the beast is a phenomenally
designed and performed creature him I
think what he just kind of stands there
is intimidating yes
but successfully intimidating there's
plenty of monsters and plenty of shows
plenty movies that are written and you
know handled like oh he would just stand
there and be intimidating but they're
not there they're not an imposing enough
force they're not shot right they don't
look right there the performer doesn't
have that presence to actually make them
intimidating the beast is legitimately
intimidating and just the way that he
arrives and they try and take him on and
just know just a world of no I really
like this performer I wish she did more
stuff he was in the 13th warrior which
is actually a movie I really like and I
should I should do a video on that
sometimes very underrated movie anyways
the build-up to it his arrival and
everything that goes on in this episode
culminating in that and just this
feeling of we are so completely screwed
which is another thing that this show
does really well there are a number of
points for these characters you really
do fear for them because the the show
has certainly by this point season 4 has
made clear that it's willing to go some
very harsh places and put these
characters through the ringer so
somebody somebody like the bee shows up
in a way that is as you know just
cathartic and build-up to is this its I
it is a great moment his arrival but I
also think it is a solid episode
throughout building up to it number 8
lullaby so this is basically Darla's
Redemption story because she she got
brought back to life as human which was
an interesting wrinkle then got turned
tried to turn angel it didn't work and
she comes back pregnant which is not
supposed to happen and that had led to
all sorts of things you know in the
episodes leading up to this again really
good payoff to several episodes worth of
build-up but them trying to run away
them trying to escape Holtz and trying
to escape the all these machinations and
all these things that all these people
who have these designs and plans for
this child and then Darla doing what I
don't think
any of us would have expected like she
hurt the most recent thing she said
brighter this was get this thing out of
me like she didn't care she just didn't
want to die but the fact that he got to
the point where she had a moment of
clarity and she staked herself and she
dissolves into dust and there's a baby
that's just left
and also this moment that would hold
like not attacking when he sees that and
I'm oh you're like oh he now sees Darla
and Angel as not monsters anymore now
they're parents that was gonna it and
then he has a the moment after that he
like oh no he just sees this as a way to
torch her angel even more and again it's
another one of those oh crap
moments so it just yeah this is good
stuff number seven here oh this is the
only episode from season one that's
gonna be on this list so don't bother
looking for any others although the one
with spike in that first season was
pretty good it wasn't quite good enough
for this list so this is the episode
where we lose Doyle and Doyle was one of
the highlights of that first season
because he was a very engaging very
charismatic very likeable character and
but he also was a coward he you know the
reason he hooked up with angel was
because he wasn't gonna you know do the
work to to work on these visions and you
know act on these things he was seeing
what no he needed angel to do that so to
see him after having had you know about
half season worth of build-up step up
and willingly sacrificed himself for
people that are like him but have it
even worse than he does have been
through worse stuff are dealing with
things that he can help it'll cost him
his life but he can help and it's the
kind of thing that he's run away from
every time up to that point and it's the
sort of thing that can be so cheesy if
you do it wrong but it's done well it's
done right it's performed right and you
feel the weight of the loss you feel the
weight of his choice and it's
really good eggs if for a character that
was one of the early highlights of the
show number six sleep tight
this was another one that is in many
ways a culmination of several episodes
worth build-up but oh god the stuff that
went on here
stuck with me so hard so this is the
episode where Wesley having had an
internal debate for several episodes up
to this point about what to do about
angel because he believes very firmly
that angel is prophesied fated to kill
Connor who's still a baby at that point
and he steals the baby and you know
makes this what is very clearly
incredibly difficult decision and he
just he makes his choice and then pays
for it
as I mentioned that's a big thing with
this show he gets his throat cut Connor
gets taken by Holtz and you know we
think God how can this possibly get any
worse and Holtz jumps through a portal
to a Hell dimension with a baby oh wow
and I I wanted to try and justify this
being a two-parter with the next episode
because I love angel like over Wesley in
the in his in his hospital room saying
Wesley you know you know this is angel
right I'm not Angelus you know that
right and unless he says yes and then he
tries to kill Wesley and but it but that
what that episode was a case of I love
that moment so much but the rest of the
episode is good but not quite as good
not as good as this one at least I don't
think it is this one
seeing Wesley have having to do that
seeing what it does to him to the team
and then him almost getting killed when
that happened to man oh somebody got
punches in this one but the best kind
number five
waiting in the wings otherwise known as
the ballet episode and one of the more
self-contained stories yeah yeah
I have to keep bringing up a lot of
times in these episodes is the stuff
that built up prior to this this is one
of the more self-contained episodes that
the show did after the first season
first season was a bit more self
contained stuff this this was a third
season yet was still fairly self
contained and it just tells a really
interesting story about obsession
control Nani being unable to let go and
we get Summer Glau who is you know kind
of become a staple in in Whedon projects
and she's really good in the part she
can dance ballet she's so I mean she
sells that amazingly but the we get that
in the connections between angel and
Cordelia and what it brings out of the
characters and some moments of levity as
well this is also one of the one of the
more fun episodes as the show continued
to get darker and darker and darker as
it went along and but even though there
are moments of levity there is a
melancholy to the whole thing that just
feels really right at the time that that
had happened this was just really
well-conceived well-executed brought
great things out of the characters this
is good stuff number four you're welcome
hundredth episode of the show and the
episode which saw the return of Cordelia
for a proper send-off for charisma
carpenter there is I don't I tried to
confirm exactly how certain we are about
the details of why she left the show
previously cuz they I know what the
story is that happened
I have trouble confirming it but
regardless her kind of closeout
previously as a character regardless of
the reason you know meta reason why why
charisma carpenter was taken out of the
show as an actress was not bad but kind
of unsatisfying and this gives closure
to her that really works wonderfully in
addition to that we get Lindsey coming
back in full-on villain mode and I know
not everybody
does I actually really like Lindsay I
like him as a character I like his
journey I like his pull back and forth
between the good the evil the selfish
the selfless and you know taking so long
to finally land somewhere and have a
sense of who he is and what it is he
wants to do and so I enjoy him as a
character I like this confrontation I
love
Cordelia in this and like I said it just
feels like the proper closure we didn't
get for her before and it was a nice
sweet send-off number three a hole in
the world this is the episode that saw
the death of Fred which was bold that
was ballsy that was not something I was
expecting because even as dark as the
show had been getting up to this point
the characters were being put through
the wringer sure but they were still
surviving
so for Fred to die just because she
opened a sarcophagus and they do
everything they can
it's not sudden it drags it lingers
she's fading and it you know it takes
time and you know time for them to run
and scramble and do all this stuff that
they can possibly think of and it
doesn't matter she still dies and she
dies in Wesley's arms and then stands up
as Illyria oh boy
why I mean the stuff that came after
that Whittle area is I love but like
what guts to kill this character off a
character who was very likable very
enjoyable had great chemistry with
multiple characters and sure the actors
stuck around but she was playing
somebody completely different with a
completely different vibe to everybody
else and you still felt the loss even
though the actress was still there and
there's just something about that moment
of Spike looking down into this pit and
the melancholy
where he just says there's a hole in the
world I feel like somebody should have
told us that that's just yeah just
that's the realization that they can't
win
they were net the instant that started
they were never gonna win no matter what
haul heavy but good number two smile
time sorry I had to couldn't help myself
but I mean come on
angel gets turned into a puppet and
spike makes fun of him but even as a
puppet he gets fangs and he could tear
somebody like this oh my god and the
fact that this comes in season 5 which
is such a heavy such a dark season this
insanity which is the best kind of it's
that like this
it's it's around the same level of Buffy
and it's musical episode with just the
fact that it is coming in a season that
is actually pretty dark pretty heavy and
this is so ridiculous yet it sells it
and makes it work and it's so much fun
on every possible level I just love that
image Oh angel has a puppet going down
this this gorg door with a sword oh my
god I could just I could just play that
on a loop for about an hour just watch
that moment it would still be great but
it's great even beyond that just the the
like it's the insanity of it and just
the enthusiasm that everybody threw
themselves at with how would this it
Creek ease the idea that is just yes so
much yes and I have a suspicion that
that woman is probably a lot of people's
favorite episode of the show and as much
as I love it it doesn't take my top spot
as hard as it was to put this list
together and as hard as it was to figure
out a ranking for a lot of it I knew
when I started what my number one was
gonna be I knew win
question other entries they moved
shifter shift around I knew this one no
doubt
number one episode of angel for me not
fade away the final episode of the show
period and as far as I am concerned it
is a perfect ending for this show and
yes I say that knowing that they didn't
plan for it to be the ending that they
were expecting to get another season it
was a highly rated show the cancellation
came out it came as a massive surprise
to the fans and to the creators of the
show and I know that they continued the
story in comic books I read some of them
I didn't like them very much to me the
show ends here and it should and the
note that it ends on is absolutely
perfect but I'll get to that because
even before that so much yes across this
Wesley dying you know taking on this
this sorcerer and just not be able to
get the job done and Illyria holding him
as he dies and giving him that moment of
feeling like he can speak to Fred again
and her feeling rage at his loss and
just the look on her face like oh she's
gonna tear up so much stuff and Lindsey
and his anger of being killed by Lauren
and Laurens sadness at having to do it
but Lindsey's just infuriation not that
he's gonna die but then he's gonna be
killed by a by a lackey yeah he thought
if he was gonna die angel was gonna kill
him look as far as he's concerned Lorne
is a third to your minion he's not
supposed to die at his hands but he does
and it's a moment that is sad for Lorne
and feels right for Lindsay his life did
not turn out the way he thought it was
going to even when he was so certain of
what he was doing nope you do not get
the ending that you think you're gonna
get and angel taking on you know the the
I god I forget that the character's name
the the one that Adam Baldwin plays that
felt really good that though really
cathartic didn't see him bite that guy's
neck that works really well but
ultimately the reason this has to take
the top spot is the very end of the
episode of the characters who are left
we've already lost Wesley Gunn is
bleeding out and is not expected to
survive much longer so we've got two
vampires and a weakened former God
facing the hordes of hell and a dragon
and they just go they just launched into
the fight and the reason this is perfect
is because this situation this scenario
these odds they're not gonna win and
they know that they can't but that's not
the point
you don't fight because you know you're
gonna win you fight because the battle
needs to be fought you fight because it
matters that somebody fights you fight
because it's the right thing to do even
if you can't win the fact that they are
staring down the barrel of certain death
no reason they should ever think that
they are gonna survive this and they
basically go well here we go and not
even in a resigned fashion enough bring
it on they will know that we were here
this is the perfect ending for this show
for the way that the show has been
progressing up to this point starting
out from this sort of weird little Buffy
offshoot and then gaining its own
identity more in the second season and
going darker and darker and getting
completely turned on its head in the
fifth season to the point that they have
fought so hard and sacrificed so much
and Angel having them literally
signed away the hope that he was given
at the end of the first season signs in
a way he's never got to get it but he's
still gonna fight because somebody has
to and he's there and he's gonna do it
and we don't need to see the fight it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if they
win all that matters is that they chose
to fight so cutting to black at the
start of the fight as far as I'm
concerned is perfect and it is why for
me that's is the best episode of angel
however I want to hear your thoughts
what are your list what do you think of
my list whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's all that stuff that you
can do I got patreon I got merch I got
t-shirts I got Twitter and podcasts and
all that stuff links for all this stuff
is down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]